the idea of being a sociable person is
nowadays heavily associated with finding
enjoyment in going to and in all
likelihood also in giving parties to be
sociable means welcoming the idea of
being in a room replete with an above
average number of other guests many of
whom will be unknown most of whom will
be holding a glass of alcohol bantering
with lights lower than they normally
would be and music somewhat higher than
required in order faithfully to catch
the details of another's voice parties
have become synonymous with sociability
because of certain underlying ideas
about what true social connection might
require and entail we assume that
sociability naturally springs up when
lots of people are put together in a
room that it means speaking a lot and
notably cheerfully about things that
have been happening in our lives that it
depends on a jokey manner and ideally on
the possession of a few entertaining
anecdotes often involving striking
coincidences but such assumptions
sidestep two sizable objections firstly
true sociability that is a real
connection between two people is almost
never built up via anything cheerful it
is the result of making ourselves
vulnerable before another person by
revealing some of what is broken lost
confused lonely and in pain within us we
build genuine connections when we dare
to exchange thoughts that might leave us
open to humiliation and judgment we make
real friends through sharing in an
uncensored and frank way a little of the
agony and confusion of being alive
secondly true sociability requires a
contexts we are generally under such
pressure to appear normal self possessed
and solid we are understandably unning
Cline's spontaneously to disclose our
true selves our default mode is without
anything sinister being meant by this to
lie about who we are and what's really
going on in our lives this suggests that
a genuinely social occasion might be
rather different from what we typically
in
which we think of a good host as someone
who makes sure there's enough wine and
at a pinch ensures people know each
other's names but in a profound sense a
good host is someone who creates the
conditions in which strangers can start
to feel safe about being sad and
desperate together
unfortunately the modern world seems
particularly resistant to anything that
seems artificial around parties which
threatens to evoke that most dreaded of
all social genres the corporate
get-together the thought is simply to
pack a room and leave the rest to nature
but a commitment to deep sociability
might lead us to recognize that we do
depend on a little artful choreography
to get us into the psychological zone in
which connections can unfold
we might need encouragement and even a
helpful lanyard to share a little of
what is sad within us we need help in
networking not in order to find new
investment opportunities but so is to
identify shared regrets humiliations and
feelings of despair parties as they are
currently structured constitute a clever
ruse by a sharp minority perhaps only
10% of humanity to persuade the rest of
us that we have been provided with a
social contact we crave but in truth it
takes a sharply insular and misanthropic
person to feel that what goes on in an
average party really counts as anything
like the requisite encounter with one's
fellow human animal if we have a
lingering horror of parties we should be
generous towards our hunches it doesn't
mean that we don't like other people
rather that we have too ambitious a
conception of social contact to put up
with what is on offer at most parties
the mark of a truly sociable person
might in many situations simply be a
strong desire to stay at home
if you're interested in coming to San
Francisco to meet us at the end of March
please click on the link on the screen
now to find out more we hope to see you
there